let's suppose you're having lunch with
to producing partners and they say we
found this great cineplex that we want
to show our film at we really mesh with
the theater owner and you say great make
sure ABC and D are done what would those
things be money-wise contract wise what
would you advise just to make sure
relationships great otherwise that's you
that's all you really it's more about
promotion at that point don't I mean
because it's a relationship on that and
it's really the time that you're
targeting of the space and then how are
you going to market your project and
that's the hard part of for walling and
that's why most people fail at it so um
I can throw one thing in there I would
tell them to make sure that they're
willing to have this this venture with
this theater chain for this evening that
they're showing your movie or however
long it is they have to be willing and
able for that to lose money they have to
they have to spend more than they expect
to make in order to make it successful
so that that theater chain or some other
theater chain will go hey we went in on
that right it's also just not about one
night never about one night it's about
it's a it truly is a tortoise and the
hare it is this is a long race and you
have to be willing to be in it for a
long long time it's possible to hit the
ball out of the park the first night
it's not likely but it's possible then
you have to go back and look at all the
the reason why they're there are
one-hit-wonder groups and music way back
when is their first song was a huge hit
they had nothing to back it up with it
would have been better for their first
song have been top 20 their second
tongue song to have been top 10 the
third song to then top five and the
fourth one to be number one so you have
to factor that you have to factor
longevity and it's hard for
it's especially hard for young people to
think about longevity people ask me all
the time did you think Dukes of Hazzard
was going to last this long and I said
anything I was going to last this long I
mean I did I didn't know that we were
all supposed to die in two thousand
remember so computers I know I'm
supposed to be terrible y2k marketing so
yeah you have to be willing to lose
money can't be about the money if it's
not about the money you'll make money if
it's about the money you won't I agree I
don't percent so what if a theater says
we don't do 5050 splits and you're going
to have to put up a screening fee of X
amount of dollars for the week or the
night there's that's all stuff that's in
negotiation and that's why you pick and
choose your times and it's all part of a
strategy on how you approach that
theater owner and that's all part of
that questionnaire what's working and
what's not working and where their weak
spots okay because we've known people
that they've wanted to screen in other
cities that were very expensive and it
was it was worth it to them to lose
money they wanted to put up whether they
had to do it on their credit card or not
a huge chunk because they wanted that
coverage in that city and the major
paper they wanted all the things that
went along with that so you feel that
maybe sometimes it is worth the risk as
long as you're not being taken advantage
of I mean there are there are folks who
will take advantage of the young
filmmaker or the young car salesman the
young whatever and just you have to be
smart you can't just say okay well I'm
going to throw out a bunch of money you
have to be smart and negotiate with them
no so a lot of its relationship to I
mean as anything in this industry you
know everything is relationship based
the relationships that you have and the
relationships that I have the theater
owners that we're going to speak with
are some are your side of the coin and
some from my side of the court right I
mean it's not like we're just calling up
cold calling its relationships that's
why you've been in the business as long
as you have and I have to but again
we're not going is she wearing it we're
in a very unique position I
I recognize that but we're taking
advantage of it if we go in and say hey
what can we do for you it's different
than somebody that nobody has any idea
who they are coming in and say what can
what can we do for you true but there's
nothing wrong with it's not unfair to
take advantage of your advantage it's
stupid not to so that's what that's what
we're going to do but we have to deliver
if someone nobody knows goes in and says
hey I want to try this I'd love to help
you out yet have you known as the
independent filmmaker friend and then
they they better deliver it doesn't mean
they have to make money they just better
do what they say they're going to do and
they better be vigilant in showing up
and making sure that that they've
they've got the advertising they said
they'd get they've done everything they
can to make sure people come to the
movie people aren't aren't mean they'll
they'll say well kid you know you really
worked hard at that better luck next
time and when when you're ready to do it
next time call me they'll do that but if
you come in and just talk in a big game
and then don't follow it up don't even
try forget it you're not going to work
for me or you or anybody in this in this
room or in the other room
you